[Music]
although virtual reality has always been
featured prominently in fictional
fictional versions of our dystopian
future for a while it seemed like it
wasn't really going to catch on in the
real world sort of like how all the
sci-fi writers in the mid-20th century
universally agreed that we'd have flying
cars by the early 21st century and yet
here we are in the actual 21st century
and the technology exists technically
and there are companies that are
actually trying to build these
contraptions flying cars
but most of us have come to realize that
that having everybody fly around in
their own personal aircraft would be a
disaster i mean most drivers can barely
manage to pilot their vehicles on the
ground it's horrifying to think about
what would happen if these drivers had
access to the sky
i guess those who made these predictions
about the future also assumed
that the average driver would have
mastered the fundamentals of using a
steering wheel by now but that has not
been the case and so flying cars have
not taken off figuratively or literally
and probably never will and if they do
take off
most of them will certainly crash and
burn about 45 seconds later
i had always hoped
that virtual reality would suffer the
same failure to launch
and i felt heartened in recent months as
mark zuckerberg unveiled his metaverse
which is his virtual reality vision and
i was encouraged to see how boring and
dull it is as we talked about on the
show zuckerberg's great vision is to
create an immersive internet experience
where people can enter inside it like
the matrix crossing through a portal
into a limitless
3d virtual reality world
where they can have meetings and
conference calls
zuckerberg's cyber universe is
considerably more boring than the
regular universe and this is what
happens when you put like spock in
charge of designing our vr utopia
but i've probably taken too much solace
in this the fact is that
there are other vr platforms aside from
the hellish corporate seminar universe
that zuckerberg is creating and vr is
like it or not catching on there are
currently about 50 million vr users in
america today the whole industry is
worth about eight billion dollars
projected to be to grow to nearly 30
billion in the next five years or so
more importantly
the most powerful corporations in the
world companies that have literally
made a science out of understanding and
predicting and manipulating our behavior
they are investing more and more into vr
technologies
we already know about what zuckerberg
and facebook are up to apple has its own
design so does microsoft and google
these companies want a future where we
are all wearing their devices on our
heads
blocking out the entire physical world
from our view and living our lives
entirely within the alternate reality
that they create for us it's not hard
why it's not hard to see why they find
that so appealing
the entertainment industry is buying in
now too hbo max will soon release what
is what is being called a groundbreaking
documentary and it's groundbreaking
because
it is the first film made entirely in
virtual reality the website vr scout has
more it says shot during the height of
the kova 19 pandemic we met in virtual
reality as an upcoming documentary from
the director hunting that follows the
lives of five specific individuals using
vr chat and modern vr technology to
connect with others in a variety of
unique ways the 90 minute film was shot
entirely in vr at no point do we learn
the real world identities of its
subjects says the director the film
presents an immersive journey through
the world and different vr chat
communities each individual that you
meet shares really unique experiences on
vr and each engages with their community
in different ways for them vr means very
different things through their eyes the
film presents a very broad portrait on
how social vr can affect our emotional
and social relationships with each other
but also within ourselves
the trailer was released a few days ago
here's a peek at that
[Music]
making friends here is sometimes what
saves people's lives
or what gets him up out of bed in the
morning
i am a teacher for helping hands a sign
language community here in vr chat hand
rested under elbow and we're gonna go
like this christmas
slow
quick quick slow if i had confidence
that i could teach dance as a living in
vr i totally would do exactly that with
a long distance relationship having vr
is a game changer
we are 5 000 miles apart but we're gonna
try our best to make it work
this year has been really hard the thing
that has kept me sane has been vr and
the vr community
i would not have weathered this without
you guys
[Music]
you can be who you've always wanted to
be and you can in a way start over
we can come together and support each
other this community means a lot to me
and i really want them to know that
they're loved
it's true in a year since i've seen
kevin's irl body
well isn't that beautiful people
connecting forming communities falling
in love
you can start over says one of the vr
fans
you could be reborn
you could be whoever you want to be
provided that you want to be a weird
creepy anime avatar like if you want to
be that you can do that
this all sounds like a utopia with no
downside at all right so what's the
problem well there are many problems it
turns out we've talked about some of
them before but let's review first of
all the documentary is filmed in the
platform on the platform vr chat but
based on the trailer it seems to rather
seems to give a rather glossy and
carefully curated view
of this vr chat platform
an article on the site engadget gives
the other side of the vr chat story
headline is
investigation of vr chat finds rampant
child grooming and other safety issues
they report quote one of the more
popular vr apps you can download through
steam and meta's oculus quest store has
a child safety problem vrchat styles as
the future of social virtual reality our
our vision for vrchat is to enable
everybody to create and share their own
social virtual worlds the games
developer says on its steam store page
with some understanding of unity uh
players can create their own social
spaces and avatars that means you can
see a lot of creativity on display in vr
chat but there's also a dark side to it
as the bbc found out
posing as a 13 year old girl bbc
researcher jess sherwood said she
entered a virtual strip club where she
saw adult men chase a child while
telling them to remove their clothes in
many of the rooms sherwood visited she
frequently saw condoms and sex toys on
display and on one occasion even saw a
group of adult men and minors simulating
group sex she also saw instances of
grooming
well it turns out that virtual reality
is even in its fetal stages
infested by perverts and pedophiles of
course no surprise
just look at what happened in our
real-life cities when we told everyone
to wear a mask
anonymity removes accountability and
removes shame which invites chaos now
put people in virtual world with full
anonymity an entirely new and fake
identity and also empower them with the
false notion that nothing is real in
cyberspace
um as if human being as if the human
beings they're interacting with don't
even count as human beings
tell them that the normal rules of
morality and decency no longer apply and
suddenly it becomes like the purge every
day all day
except more sexual and with a lot more
child molesters this is just one of the
problems with virtual reality the fact
that the internet is a is a hellish
place where people act monstrous towards
each other because they feel empowered
to do so
but that's not the full indictment
i mean in theory putting all the sex
predators aside for a moment which is
very hard to do
when you're talking about anything
related to the internet
um but putting that aside
there's nothing wrong with vr and small
doses as a fun gimmicky little diversion
but we know that people in our culture
don't engage in escapism entertainment
in small doses they turn it into a
lifestyle
that's why even in the in the trailer
for the documentary we begin with some
users discussing practical applications
for the technology teaching sign
language for instance seems like a okay
yeah that's that's one area where it
seems like that would be um that would
make sense
but very quickly we start hearing how vr
is really an opportunity to form loving
bonds and find community and reinvent
yourself and restart your life and find
meaning and everything else
so the pipeline from escapis escapism
entertainment to lifestyle choice is
short and the transition from one to the
other happens at near lightning speed
we are a culture obsessed with escaping
vr offers the most complete form of
escape short of suicide
the user can block the entire physical
world from view enter into the internet
recreate themselves according to their
own vision or rather according to the
vision of apple or microsoft or facebook
which they will be tricked into thinking
is their own vision
this grants almost unlimited power to
these tech giants allowing them to
control manipulate track and monetize
your every movement literally
i mean think about for a second or what
they do on the social media platforms um
the way they're able to predict your
behavior just based on just based on
what you search for and you know like
the kinds of posts you click on and
everything
that's why people often think when they
see ads pop up and uh and they they
think oh the phone's listening to me no
it's not listening to you it's even
worse than that they've built technology
that can just predict what you are going
to want it they can predict the kind of
ad
like you were just talking about
something you want to buy you've never
searched for it before and then the ad
pops up
no the phone didn't hear you say that it
just predicted based on your behavior
that you would want a product like that
and then you did
which is a lot scarier
now give them that kind of predictive
capability
when they can also track your movements
everything
what happens then
but worse if it further severs you from
your physical existence and your actual
true physical self now it sounds like
new like sort of new age claptrap to say
that people need to be reconnected with
themselves you know find themselves and
it is new age claptrap but in this case
the new age claptrap is inadvertently
true
as human beings in modern culture
you know we find various and ever more
elaborate ways of hiding from ourselves
shrinking away from our actual lives and
bodies
and as that happens the job of rescuing
society from collapse and despair
revolves more and more around
encouraging people to live authentically
be yourself not in the bumper stick or
slogan kind of way but in a deeper more
urgent sense
inhabit your own life be yourself
yourself
live in and interact with and see the
world the physical world accept it and
understand it and appreciate it for what
it is
these days we're always
out looking for any kind of reality but
our actual reality
[Music]
and that's why our actual reality never
improves
and that's why virtual reality is once
again today
cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts
you